I will try to make this under two
minutes first of all thank you to the
Academy Thank You Sean Hector and the
team for a wonderful week and I'd like
to thank my sound designer Florian comer
who responded to my cry of help email
and really bringing the film to life I'd
like to thank my mom and dad for their
everlasting support and my mom who's
here tonight my mom gave me so many
children's books for me to read when I
was a little kid and those books ended
up being my main inspiration and reason
to make this film and I'd like to thank
her for giving me all this inspiration
after all these years and I'd like to
thank the faculty at Cal arts especially
my film workshop instructor Frank Krauss
and my mentor and reebok for letting me
create whatever story I wanted to make
and they saw the importance of letting
the students be the creators of their
own films and supported the beginning to
the very end of making this film and
lastly to my dearest friends some of
them are here tonight not only are you
my classmates at school but you were
also the best and Onex honest critics
that I could ever ask for I thank you
for teaching me to have nerves of steel
when I ever wanted to give up and
somehow you'll find the recording of
this video later to make fun of me for
the rest of the school year I love you
guys and thank you thank you so much for
your hard